foreign
the first photos of Jennifer Lopez's
wedding dress are finally here and like
we knew she would JLo brought the Glam
with not one but three custom Ralph
Lauren gowns to marry hubby Ben Affleck
three days after bennifer celebrated
their love with a second wedding at
Ben's 87 acre Georgia estate surrounded
by their loved ones and A-list Pals the
singer clued in her fans on her lavish
looks with a newsletter blast I always
have fun with fashion JLo posted a
close-up wearing her cathedral-length
veil and gave fans these glimpses of her
wedding wardrobe on her blog
ET has learned jyn walked down the aisle
to Ben and this romantic look created by
Ralph Lauren the brand showed off the
making of Jen's gown on their socials
[Music]
dress number one a reimagined turtleneck
column dress with a dramatic ruffle
skirt and open back it took over 100
hand-cut handkerchiefs and 500 meters of
fabric cut into Ruffles to assemble
JLo's ceremony look it just turned out
to be something really magical and while
Jen seemed to keep her first look on the
more traditional side she turned up the
heat with a sexy fitted gown for her
next look
the details are unreal get this it took
30 hands on deck and over 700 hours to
hand embroider JLo's gown featuring
thousands of cascading strings of pearls
silk tulle and Swarovski crystals and as
if two quick changes weren't enough the
show-stopping bride pulled out another
Custom Creation that showed off her
curves
dress number three a mermaid style gown
with a keyhole neckline embellished with
Swarovski Crystals and a full skirt
draped in organza we are living for this
major bridal Moment and we hear beneford
2.0's big day was one for the books a
source tells E.T Jin and Ben were elated
the entire weekend we're super happy
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time yeah we're told Jen and Ben
are in newlywed Blitz quote married life
is still fresh of course but Jen and Ben
are so excited to have formally shared
their bonding experience with their
closest friends and family it's just a
dream come true
[Music]
thank you